okay let's do Josh because he wants to
talk about some wife school so Josh what
do you got from everybody with wife
School
have you heard of just pearly things
have I heard of yeah Pearl uh Pearl had
me on for a interview like three four
years ago when she was a nobody so I
know who she is yeah I was just curious
what you make of this wife's school
thing that she's doing do you think it's
full
and what advice do you have for her that
she could take on board
well I mean
what do you want me to start with man so
tell me about the wife school so so I'm
assuming she's going to be lecturing
women on how to be wives yeah they've
also got like what's his name Troy
Francis
I don't know too much about it I know
that I've only like seen a little bit of
it there's like an hour long
well look I mean the first rule of wife
school should be be a virgin yep and
yeah that's what Muslims are going to be
preaching well I mean like is she a
virgin I don't think so I mean she's got
a large Knox County she's already said
she already said that as well yeah so
why is she in a position to lecture you
know the gals about wife schooling
your guess is just as good as mine Rich
legitimate question right
see there's this new there's this new
era of uh
well they're not track cons like like
they're always wall post wall women I
don't know how old Pearl is she looks
like she's in her late 20s maybe early
30s or something like that but you're
like 26. oh she looks old she does
he's 27 but looks younger than that
which is yeah so so all of these gals
have now entered the Mano swap because
because they see that there's guys that
are that are struggling with women and
they also know that they've throughout
their entire lives had the attention of
guys unanimously freely you know thrown
at them so when they start talking about
the sorts of Notions and ideas that I've
talked about for years or even other
guys that are in the space have
um you know dispensed they just
basically say the same thing without any
real frame around it and because they've
got their hair and makeup done then you
get these Geeks that watch this stuff
and they consume it you know ravenously
and it's like oh look you know another
video from so and so and she's going to
talk about this and why you know women
have to be this way if they want to get
guys and like none of these girls want
to bang the guys that are watching them
is you know the truth of the matter all
you're doing is you're feeding and
stroking the Rigo with more of their
nonsense they're not saying anything
Innovative and truthfully at the end of
the day they don't even understand the
male struggle nobody understands a male
struggle except yeah only a guy that's
like been rejected only a guy that's
chased a girl that you know shot him
down knows the struggle of a man none of
them any advice um for dating um men
towards women could be from her father
or or her brothers like you've got a
daughter you could have to have this
conversation with I wonder how she how
old is she now you know these these
these gals need to step aside and let
the guys handle it you know is really
what it boils down to they're not
they're not offering anything useful to
men if anything it's just a distraction
from the reality of things guys Chase
excellent put a dent in the universe
become competent become something useful
to yourselves develop a strong masculine
flame you know how to fight 1.62 golden
ratio can you make money do you know how
to make it rain right because money
solves a lot of problems all these
tricks are doing is just sitting there
saying things that we've said years ago
and then they're getting attention for
it because they say it with a bra and
makeup on and lipstick right yep that's
very intriguing so no I'm not a huge fan
of it let them carry on you know it's
it's better than them doing uh shopping
hauls you know I suppose or only fans or
only fans but yeah let's be honest I
mean look unless you're a virgin okay
and you're you're a competent woman
that's gonna that has a capacity to
enter the frame of a guy and and support
his life and his mission I don't I don't
really care what you have to say about
wife School
stop stop women from being so
promiscuous then we can have a
conversation about your wife's School
let's start there but they'll never do
that because women have been told their
entire lives do whatever you want you
can be like a man go chase Excellence
hang as many dudes as you want there's
no consequences it's disgusting
STDs it's it's only when they come to
the realization themselves when they get
older into their later 20s or in their
30s oh [ __ ] they're like stupid [ __ ] and
these guys over here are saying the
right thing so I'm gonna go say the
right things too and I'm going to copy
them
that's how it goes
yeah anyway Josh do you get the idea
right yep
thanks brother I really hope you guys
enjoyed that clip if you want to watch
the full length podcast you can find
that over here that clips from if you're
new to the channel make sure you hit
subscribe over here and pin down below
in the top comment you'll find a bunch
of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out